fabienne de klose bonjour bonjour alors
à juliette est sorti il ya un mois
comment déjà vous en est devenu al
écrire cet ouvrage
à force de lire et écrire des grands
mères ma détresse d'avoir perdu juliette
et sachant qu'il avait vécu la même
chose j'ai commencé à faire des ateliers
d'écriture dès le mois d'avril est donc
dans six ateliers d'écriture je me suis
rendu compte que ça me faisait du bien
d'écrire et de poser des mots justes sur
ce que je ressentais et au fil du temps
j'ai fait plus en plus d'ateliers
diverses avec différentes personnes
et voilà comment es tu arrivé à l'idée
d'écrire et c'est ça qui est naturel et
vous avez choisi de l'adresser à
juliette voulu parler tout le temps mais
qui était-elle juliette juliette c'était
une petite fille très venir je trouve ma
fille et sa maman un peu mystérieuse
malgré tous vos qui au fil du temps
séparé un peu sa vie de famille où tout
se passe est vraiment très bien on était
une famille vraiment soudée nous a
beaucoup de choses ensemble
le week-end de la corse juliette était
une passionnée et passionné de piano de
gymnastique c'est
d'aviation et de bulle fr pilotes de
ligne et est donc où est donc elle s'est
parée vraiment c'est sous les lieux avec
ses amis l'école de ce qu'ont fait pas
beaucoup sur ce qui se passait et je
pense que ses amis ne connaissent pas et
vul est comme on la connaît et vice
versa juliette était un enfant a un
potentiel je dis dans mon livre et cette
fois là sont vraiment différents enfin
certains suis peut-être pas tous
beaucoup plus sensibles beaucoup plus
sais-tu à la recherche de réponses et
qui l avait beaucoup de peurs de phobies
ni de peur de la mort ça se passe
vraiment constante une recherche du sens
de la vie qui a été assez présent en
fait pour alain son suicide est une
surprise pour vous c'est ce qu'on
ressent dans les premières pages de
votre ouvrage d'écrire un tel livre
c'est aussi pour alerter et informer si
nous ne sommes plus un tabou oui oui oui
mais ça a été une complète surprise voté
vent a tiré parce qu'on ne s'y attendait
pas du tout on met de rentrer de
vacances mois d'août on était en corse
on était bien on a fait ses 14 ans et
intègre aux vraiment pas de signe d'
alerte après la commencer l'année
en disant je vais absolument prendre des
cours de maths particulier pour pour
réussir malgré tout pour faire un pilote
de l'est mais elle se projetaient est
vraiment à l'été rentrer en seconde avec
des amis elle a pas vraiment une vie
sociale très elle était assez populaire
juliette est donc évidemment content
quand elle fait ça on est complètement
atterrée et pour la écrire pour déjà
pour parler du tabou du suicide parce
que c'est vraiment l'impression que si
on lit un livre sur suicide y est où on
va se suicider que c'est c'est un tel
tabou même de nos jours
et pourtant c'est la deuxième cause de
mortalité chez les jeunes au suicide
donc je pense que j'espère que si les
jeunes lisent mon livre enfin déjà j'ai
eu des retours de jeunes qui m'ont dit
mais on se rend compte de ce que ça
laisse après ce qu'ils font passer un
peu de suicide
donc il se rend compte de vraiment delà
de la famille qui laisse après derrière
de la réalité du suicide ont fait c'est
justement dans le voir vous ne cachez
jamais votre douleur nombre de
souffrances et l'impact que ça va sur
votre époux et vous de vos deux autres
filles jeunes ans parce que si on
témoigne il faut ne pas cacher parce que
si on commença à cacher a pas dire des
choses parce que il faut pas parce que
après c'est plus un témoignage c'est
plus juste
je voulais que cela soit vraiment juste
ça ressemble presque à un journal intime
oui tout est très précis vous avez tous
gardés dans votre mémoire
depuis le 1er janvier même la veille 2
oui je suis l'élu est oui bah j'ai tout
j'ai écrit j'ai repris des mails que
j'avais écrit un patrick et
relisons parce que je mets écrivait tous
quotidiennement
donc là où il gère bien j'ai pu
retrouver puis j'ai créé 26 sur un
cahier jeu je pense que j'ai commencé à
écrire parce que j'ai redit justement
relu les mecs je vais envoyer le 16
janvier j'ai commencé à écrire à lui
dire je vais vous avez écrit ses livres
sur sol est né à gimat je vais essayer
de faire pareil
vous terminez avec une phrase s'il te
plaît juliette fait moi ainsi on est en
octobre 2017 quand vous décrivez
aujourd'hui est ce que vous attendez
toujours vous avez passé un nouveau cap
peut-être avec la sortie d'un ouvrage
j'ai attendu cet ouvrage me portent
beaucoup en fait ça m'aide
oui ça me porte en fait c'est le mot
juste et j'attends toujours un signe de
juliette way j'attends
j'ai moins bien après tout dit mais le
fait que tu écris ce un signe il ya
plein de choses comme ça
après je dis bien le fait pourquoi j'ai
écrit un ppda
le 4 janvier deux joueurs deux jours
après c'est quand j'ai réfléchi je me
sers impressionnant pourquoi pourquoi je
l'écris pourquoi ça dérange mais dans la
tête qu'il avait écrit sur solène et
j'ai pas de réponse alors est plus ce
sont les signes je sais pas merci fabien
ne close alors on vous en prie à
juliette est publié chez flammarion
depuis le 9 mai